now watch me now now okay now watch me  whip whip watch me nae nae it's the  dance craze taken over the world and now  the Dancing with the Stars season 21  cast are showing how they whip and nae  nae I watch me whip kill it now watch me  nae nae bindi Irwin draped with a snake  around her shoulders looks like she's  ready to hit the dance floor  but judging by these Nene's it looks  like bindi already has some tough  competition now watch me whip kill it  now watch me nae nae okay now watch me  whip kill it now watch me nae nae  clearly Nick Carter has been brushing up  on his boyband moves now watch me whip  whip watch me nae nae even Chaka Khan  got in on the fun now watch me whip kill  it now watch me nae nae okay